Harlequin is a pop culture phenomenon
but this fan favorite character is
consistently framed by her relationships
almost all of which are dangerously
toxic and not just with the Joker
Harley's life is full of characters who
rarely have her best interests at heart
why can't we simply move past people
like that in our lives
why can't Harley just quit the Joker who
was responsible for making Harley all
Harley ish is it Gotham the Joker Batman
we wanted to talk with someone in the
mental health field about Harley Quinn's
relationships and how they help or hurt
hi my name is dr. Dre Ola to Mandy I'm a
clinical psychologist writer for fandom
and host of the podcast the Arkham
sessions of course the character Harley
is most closely associated with is the
Joker so the big question is the Joker
truly responsible for creating Harley
Quinn she thought she was curing him but
she was falling in love it's really hard
to say whether one event or one person
one relationship is the catalyst for a
major change in personality or in
Psychological features but I do think
that the Joker's relationship with
Harley and the types of things that he
does to her really impact her mental
health and the manifestation of some of
her symptoms later on one could say that
her experiences with him were
interpersonally traumatic and
emotionally painful and and she's found
a way to reconcile that by associating
love with emotional pain love with abuse
love with being controlled and and
that's not uncommon I think I could
definitely see that becoming a pattern
with Harley such that she then begins to
relate to other people with a power
dynamic normals is sitting on the dryer
people like us we don't get nor why is
it always a North part every
single time you open your mouth having
said that there may have been some
pre-existing personality attributes that
Harley just had well I've always had an
attraction for extreme personalities
they're more exciting more challenging
one is the idea that she really went for
it in terms of seeing the Joker as a
human being like wanting to treat him
wanting to heal him and while I think
that's really admirable they're signs
that her willingness to be isolated with
him to be one-on-one with him is a
pre-existing sign that she had a
predisposition to threatening situations
or an interest in high-risk situations
that would be a sign of something to be
worried about even before they started a
relationship together whether it's a
Greek tragedy or an episode of Batman
the Animated Series
you can't tell a story without an
inciting incident and they're rarely
pretty but can the traumatic events
fiction puts its characters through
actually make people stronger it is
important for us to experience adversity
it's how we build resilience which is
our ability to get back up again after
experiencing setbacks and Batman really
embodies this concept of resilience that
he can be punched and kicked so many
times and he still gets up it's very
symbolic but it's also somewhat accurate
in the sense that those challenging
experiences give us these really
important psychological lessons this
rings true for Harley Quinn as well in
that she's able to learn from some of
the challenges and difficulties
interpersonally while Harley is drawn to
risky situations and unhealthy
relationships she sometimes will
understand how those experiences will
keep her from healing one of those
concepts has to do with reach Ramah
decision so the idea that rather than be
open to other maybe more healthy
relationships she turns right back
toward really volatile abusive
controlling types of relationships
typically it's with the Joker but there
are other people that really try to
harness the
like power dynamic with her as well
which leads to people like Amanda Waller
who is more than willing to take
advantage of Harley Quinn's mental
health I use it to maybe when Harley is
recruited into Task Force X she knows
that her asset like her ability there is
this craziness this kind of identity
that Waller places on her what was that
I should kill everyone in this gate
sorry the voices this commingling of her
mental instability connected to danger
connected to some willingness to go into
really risky situations to be suicidal
to be violent to be homicidal and I
think that while that message is
incorrect it's inaccurate that's kind of
where her places with Suicide Squad
she's there because she's a ticking time
bomb and Waller knows that her placement
there is about her willingness to go
into these high-risk situations complete
the mission you get time off your prison
sentence failed a mission you die if she
weren't in Suicide Squad she would still
be engaging in some pretty risky
situations sensation-seeking situations
ones that would pump up her adrenaline
ones that would make her feel alive for
someone like Harley she needs to kind of
dial up those situations in order to
feel a sense of existence of power of
mattering in the world and I think
that's what makes her positioning in in
Suicide Squad make a lot of sense but
it's also actually quite it's abusive I
think Waller takes advantage of the
situation by putting her in these
environments where Harley is going to be
triggered again and again and again
family tells me a whole lot of people
are about to die
does Harley need to get the heck out of
Gotham to heal and grow
or are there actual benefits to Harley
hanging out with crocodile men and guys
that throw boomerangs and you know come
through Harley is the right person to be
in Suicide Squad or in Task Force X but
she's actually the first to be really
into it to be pretty enthusiastic about
parts of the mission and I'm certain
that having purpose is really important
for her so as a psychiatry intern her
purpose was to heal she in fact had one
of the most challenging patients right
the Joker is one of the most complicated
cases that she ever had and she took on
that challenge and showed that she is
trying to find purpose in life and yet
despite Suicide Squad giving her a sense
of validation and meaning the bigger
picture might keep her from making
progress psychologically but this is
certainly a landscape that is constantly
introducing threats and dangers and that
she may not be able to get out of this
constant search for adrenaline this
constant search for wanting to feel
alive and finding that in Gotham City
that is exactly the right place for her
if she's going to be putting herself in
constant situations of risk while Harley
continues to make friends for less than
healthy reasons we'll keep rooting for
her to come out on top and maybe spend
some more time with poison ivy she seems
like a nice girl
[Music]